ce sont encore ceux qui vivent en zones
de conflit
qui sont les plus mal alimenté le
rapport de l'unicef affirme que 50
millions d'enfants de moins de cinq ans
souffrent des massias ion ou sont trop
maigres pour leur taille
il y en a trois fois plus soit 149
millions qui présentent un retard de
croissance sur la planète
un enfant sur deux souffre de carences
en suivant la fin espionner passe
quelque chose qu'on voit pas mais qui a
quand même un impact important sur le
développement physique et mental de
l'enfant près de 45 % des bébés âgés de
six mois à deux ans il ne consomme pas
de fruits ni légumes nous dit l'unicef
près de 60 % d'entre eux ne mangent ni
eux ni viande ni produits laitiers il ya
des enfants qui ne mangent pas
suffisamment ce dont ils ont besoin mais
il ya aussi de l'autre côté du surpoids
c'est la grande surprise de ce rapport
l'obésité causés par la surconsommation
de produits alimentaires transformés et
la restauration rapide
résultat 3 140 millions d'enfants de
moins de cinq ans souffrent de carences
liées à la consommation de ces aliments
transformés
un enfant qui est obèse ou quittent en
surpoids c'est un risque que ça devienne
un adulte également sur quoi donc à
terme ça va poser d'énormes problèmes
pour ses économies pour ces sociétés
enfin le réchauffement climatique créé
une série de problèmes graves liées aux
perturbations fréquentes de la
production alimentaire sécheresse
dragueur qu'il faut responsable à 80 %
des pertes agricoles
ça aussi ça amène des gens n'ont qu'à
vit en zone urbaine souvent dans les
mêmes dans les bidonvilles où on encore
moins accès à certains aliments
les solutions existent elles sont
connues taxation sur les boissons
gazeuses
une simple mesure comme ça que aider
déjà à diminuer la consommation aéré et
éventuellement instruit les problèmes de
surpoids il est important aujourd'hui de
pouvoir retourner la machine est de
pouvoir promouvoir à nouveau des animaux
aliments sains et équilibrés à la portée
de tous
l'agencé onusienne fait appel au
gouvernement pour l'éducation des
enfants et de leurs parents mais surtout
pour mettre ou pas les entreprises du
secteur privé
ici c'est dans les jardins radio canada
montréal